hey youtubers it's Charlie so the flash
producers have teased us with the idea
of the multiverse the idea of multiple
timelines so what I'm gonna do is
explain the history of the DC multiverse
that comic book multiverse and then
explain how the TV show might adapt that
a lot of you have also asked if the
flash multiverse will create a backdoor
to connect the TV shows with the movies
and that's not the case anything you see
on TV will have nothing to do with
what's going on in Batman V Superman or
any of the other movies the very first
version of the comic book multiverse
started out in 1940 in all-star comics
number three it was actually a pretty
light crossover between characters it
was the first official meeting of the
Golden Age Justice Society of America
Justice League didn't become a thing
till 1960 the first Justice Society was
Johnny Thunder the Jay Garrick flash
Hawkman the Jim Corrigan Spectre our man
the ma hunkel Red Tornado the Wesley
Dodds Sandman dr. faith the out prat
atom in the Alan Scott Green Lantern
funny fact at the time Hawk man's weapon
was called the hammer of Thor yeah and
I'm sure Marvel's lawyers really like
that Johnny Thunders magic Thunderbolt
brought them all together and they just
took turns telling each of their most
interesting stories the reason why they
call it a multiverse story is is because
prior to this the other characters
didn't exist in each other's titles so
like the Alan Scott Green Lantern didn't
reference Batman in his comics the first
multiple earths situation didn't show up
till 1959 in Wonder Woman number 59 she
gets transported to an alternate earth
and meets a woman named Tara Taruna who
looks just like her basically like that
Earth's version of Wonder Woman what you
know is the multiverse today really
started out during the Silver Age in the
flash of two worlds the Barry Allen
flash debuted in showcase number four in
1956 it was part of the big Silver Age
reboot they fridge all their Golden Age
characters and just reimagined them in
new more interesting ways that showcase
issue was just to flash stories it told
the story of how he got struck by the
Thunderbolt and got SuperSpeed but they
hadn't invented the idea of the Speed
Force yet so it was just a normal
lightning bolt it was also the first
appearance of his costume ring and the
first time that he timed travel by going
SuperSpeed so everybody loves Barry
Allen all is right with the world
but they get the idea for him to phase
into another earth and he meets jay
garrick this is flash of two worlds this
was in 1963 the way they explained it is
is that he was trying to do a party
trick in Central City and vibrated his
molecules so that he would look
invisible but instead he ends up
appearing in front of another city that
ends up being Keystone City which at
this time was an alternate earth so he
meets Jay Garrick and learns about the
other flash just to tie it back to the
TV show for a second so Central City is
where the particle accelerator is on
this side of the river on the other side
of the river is Keystone City so they
sit right next to each other but that's
the TV show it didn't start out that way
in the comics Keystone City used to only
be on another earth later that earth
became earth too and they started
introducing the naming convention where
you have earth one earth two then you
have the multiverse with like earth X
earth s for all these different
characters so we're still in the 1960s
right now we're a long ways away from
crisis on Infinite Earths in the 80s
what happened is is that the flash of
two worlds was such a popular story that
DC decided to bring back all of its
Golden Age characters and just put them
on earth too so now they could tell
stories with their old characters
without it complicating what was going
on with their Silver Age characters and
they could always do crossovers the
first big falero type crossover they did
was later in 1963 just like a couple
months after they did flash of two
worlds they had the Silver Age Justice
League crossover with the Golden Age
Justice Society that became like a
yearly thing like their yearly version
of Flair Oh for the next twenty years
after that DC's slowly gained the rights
to characters and tried to fold them
into continuity so they started
introducing the idea of earth s first X
like all these different earths
that's where you get to the shitstorm of
continuity errors that led to crisis on
Infinite Earths but originally crisis
was meant to be like a 50th anniversary
story Marv Wolfman is the one that wrote
crisis on Infinite Earths but the idea
was pitched that they would use this
event to clean up their continuity
because it is just gotten so crazy
editorial was just having way too many
problems keeping track of all their
characters so post-crisis what you have
is a single
with a single timeline and all the
survivors of crisis on Infinite Earths
so
some of the Golden Age characters
survived most of them were killed off
especially a lot of the crazier
characters so it was all born out of
editorial just trying to simplify things
but eventually things spun out of
control all kinds of continuity errors
despite all the trouble they'd gone
through and you get to zero hour zero
hour was like the next big event meant
to clean up a bunch of different
timelines it was more about multiple
timelines collapsing than multiple
earths collapsing so just a small
distinction everybody be sure to give
Hal Jordan a big pat on the back for
that cleanup the problem is is that
continuity errors kept happening again
and again and again you get to Hypertime
as a way to explain things with multiple
different timelines you get to Infinite
Crisis which brings back the multiverse
from pre crisis on Infinite Earths or
already this is like spinning out of
control you could say it gets super
complicated post flashpoint there were
fifty two versions of earth left they
felt like this was enough to have some
really cool crossovers and a bunch of
different versions of characters enough
so that it wouldn't get too complicated
but that ended up being the case anyway
so that's where you get to the big
convergence event right now where
they're trying to collapse a bunch of
timelines get rid of a bunch of stuff
reboot the characters that's why they
keep advertising the new DC Universe so
in the comics the multiverse is all
about multiple versions of characters
sharing the same physical space together
like talking to each other the TV show
probably not gonna go that route they'll
probably go the alternate timeline route
that doesn't even begin to get into the
idea of the positive matter universe in
the antimatter universe that's actually
Geoff Johns is actually playing with
that idea in the Darkseid war title that
he's writing right now it's happening in
Justice League it's part of the Justice
League title any way you look at it
though the comic book multiverse from a
logistical standpoint is a complete
nightmare
so that's why TV shows thus far have
tried to avoid it
Smallville did try to do a version of
the multiverse using the mirror box
where you know you have like crime
syndicate version of Clark a lot of you
did s2 during the flash finale if you
know when we see the flash Museum and
killer frost
if that's part of the multiverse -
technically it's not it's really just
different points in Barry's single
timeline like in his own timeline he
wasn't seeing different branches so like
killer frost for instance happens in the
future of his own timeline but what
about the Jay Garrick helmet how do you
explain
that is that from the future is that
from the past like where did it come
from the way I'm choosing to think about
it at least until the flash writers and
the producers tell us otherwise is that
that vortex they created is kind of like
a time-space train depot that anybody
can enter if they achieve the right
speed or have the right technology they
really haven't told us that much so I
don't want to speculate too much on
where that Jay Garrick helmet came from
but I know a lot of you guys are hoping
that John Wesley Shipp will get to be
like an alternate timeline version of
the flash he'll be like the Jay Garrick
flash they could do that it's a little
on the nose I'm not expecting it the
producers did say we would see multiple
versions of the flash Wally West is the
only one that they've said out loud but
they did show us the Jay Garrick helmet
so that's the other flash there so when
they say multiple flashes they could
just mean references to other flashes
instead of like actually casting actors
as them but I do feel like when the show
gets to Wally West it'll be an actual
actor they will cast him and we'll see
him interact with baring the other
characters really you have to remember
that the TV shows number one mission is
to do an interesting story and keep it
as easy to follow as possible so it's
like you know if you don't read comics
you need to be able to follow this
time-travel storyline that's why I don't
think they're gonna get really crazy
with the comic book multiverse it look
it'll be relatively simple and will stay
in this single timeline it's just this
giant vortex the Bears trying to close
will allow some stuff from alternate
timelines to spill into our timeline
they'll use it as a storytelling device
the same way they use the particle
accelerator explosion during season 1 to
create all the metahumans so think of it
as a giant mixing bowl across time and
space that it's probably gonna take
Barry the first two episodes to close
and I do think he'll close it in the
first couple of episodes but not before
it allows a whole bunch of other stuff
to spill into their timeline right away
I can say that Tom Cavanagh is still a
series regular so he'll come back on the
show in an alternate form probably like
the original Harrison wells one that did
not get killed by the reverse-flash
Eddie coming back is a little bit harder
but they said that he would appear at
least a couple times but only as a guest
star that could be in flashback so it
could be alternate timelines it's just
that they're slowly dipping their toe in
the idea of Barry time-traveling because
he's still figuring things out he's
probably gonna make some derps and
that's probably what's gonna lead to
some of these alternate timeline
showing up but for the most part like
from a story perspective most of this is
gonna flow from that giant vortex in the
sky everybody hold their breath for the
TARDIS to come down and Android us stick
his head out before legends of tomorrow
time-travel gonna be a big thing in
flash season two you have to remember
that legends of tomorrow is a time
travel based story so part of that is
going to inform what's going on with
Vandal Savage here's my big question for
you guys though where do you think that
that Jay Garrick helmet came from in the
flash finale is that from the past of
Barry's own timeline or is that from an
alternate universe for the most part
though I'm expecting the idea of just
you know multiple timelines where
characters make different choices
leading to different outcomes that being
said Caitlin snow supposedly going to be
turning to killer frost I think that
will be our version of Caitlin it's not
going to be an alternate universe
version of Caitlin so because I haven't
done a video on that character yet what
I'm probably gonna do is my next bonus
video will just be all killer frost so
be sure to subscribe to get that they
haven't announced any other new
characters yet but if there's anybody
that you want me to do a video on just
let me know in the comments I know a lot
you guys really want me to do a
Supergirl pilot video so I'll probably
that next week I feel like it's okay now
enough enough time has passed why you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here to learn all about your master in
the comics and what's going on with him
in season 2 and you can click here to
learn about all my favorite games from
e3 this year thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow